we love a good snack and so does ryan
gosling but the actor had to make some
tough calls while pinning some of
canada's best fights against uk delights
in an interview with la bible yes a
tough job for sure not only did we get
some gift worthy reactions from ryan but
the actor validated canadians everywhere
when he called out the mispronunciation
of putin oh you don't say it like that i
don't
[Laughter]
that's putin yeah
no idea what that is so that's a pork
pie
whoa
have you had this before uh yeah
this is um
[Music]
there's got to be a better way to to
bite this i don't want to create a gift
factory here
[Laughter]
oh yeah
i mean
you're a fan of printing yes so am i
pronouncing it
you are
i don't like that its name is
puts in
i wish it were not puts in okay
americans say poutine what are you
saying you're saying i just said i'm so
sorry
oh you don't need to apologize
it is that
unfortunately this is
wow
okay well just texturally i'm gonna i'm
already we're having a problem
feel free to put some mustard on as well
okay
but then are we judging the thing or are
we judging sauces does it need mustard
so it's like the male like mustard and
pork pine together
excuse me
okay is there like a jelly in here is
that a meat is that a meat jelly uh yeah
yeah oh
that does not
sound good yeah
i mean gravy's a gravy's like a metaphor
for things going good right it's all
gravy yeah meat jelly is not meat jelly
is like something someone calls you in
junior high and you never let it down
i'm gonna go
put in to be fair i do say poutine so do
i i actually did not know and i feel
really bad that i didn't know it was
putin i didn't know i'm and like there
are people that say it that way sure
but i mean know them when we're like
when it's late at night and you're
hungry like yo you wanna get some
poutine yeah
yeah it's the poo and the tea yeah but
anyway i think either way it tastes
great don't look at me like that what i
know you didn't like the way i said it
but the
it's yeah it's good though it's good
stuff yeah i mean if you're watching
you've had some fruit right like you
know
it's hard to beat some some uh tin
poutine right i'm still gonna say it
right now anyways ryan also tried the
nymo bars versus tea cakes
frago which is apparently a british
version of dairy milk versus turtles and
one of his favorites and mine all
dressed chips versus something called
monster munch was a close battle but no
surprise here ryan chose mostly canadian
snacks to win carlos when it comes to
our canadian snacks
which do you reach for
it's number one and number two all
dressed chips and ketchup chips all
dressed i'm a chip if you had to pick
one of those chips
do you have to pick i mean listen if you
was like we're having one night of
snacks and like i have i'm only getting
one bag what are we getting i feel like
that's a very
that's a tough restriction what are like
what are we is inflation that bad yeah
one one bag of chips bag of chips what
about us what about a medium-sized
augusta and a medium-sized cake
lays or whoever makes those wants to do
a multi-bag what if you did a multi-bag
wait with all of them in one bag yeah
no you could have a ziploc bag halfway
through and then you unzip it and then
there's the all dress on the bottom and
the ketchup ones on the top there used
to be a cereal that was like that i just
call it canadian a box of cereal with
two different cereal flavors in
different bags but in one box
i remember that when i was kidding
anyways i'm i'm going if i have to pick
one
i'm picking them both i'm sorry you
can't make me decide between my two
favorite children all dressed chips and
ketchup chips
my actual kids aren't watching this by
the way
that's fine
[Music]